Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I am just checking in on you.
That's it.
You might notice my voice is a couple octaves lower.
I've been doing shows all this week.
Um,
and I was sick like a month ago,
so I don't know that it's fucking recovered,
but uh,
I don't have my usual,
uh,
you know,
mid range voice,
but this,
I promise you this is me
anyways.
Um,
I'm up here in San Francisco with the North's theater with a Nate Kraig.
We've been having a great time all week.
Um,
last night,
you know,
it was one of those nights,
she had a great show.
It was like I didn't want to fucking go home,
so we ended up going over to a,
was just walking around and ended up just at the Fillmore.
So we walk,
oh,
it goes to go fucking go over there,
have a drink or something.
Right,
because Billy's off the wagon again.
Right.
I guess when I get home I'll get back on the fucking wagon.
I'm the worst.
I'm either on or I'm off and I'm off.
Yeah,
baby.
Sorry.
Um,
by the way,
if you want to see arguably some of the funniest shit on the Internet.
Nay.
Craig told me about Kyle done against a Instagram page and I guess Joe Rogan and
Thompson Gora.
Those guys have all hyped it.
I,
I've been completely out of the loop.
That guy's one of the funniest fucking comedians.
I've always been a huge fan of his stuff and um,
and I thought he was so fucking original,
but I,
his Instagram page,
I can't even describe how,
how fucking hilarious I was the like every morning for like the last three days
I've been watching all of his videos for like an hour,
just laying in bed crying,
laughing.
Um,
his Instagram is at Kyle Dunnigan,
I g.
A n hope is spelt that right and the number one.
And he does like that face swap thing and he does this fucking ridiculous
impression of everybody.
Bill Maher,
Donald Trump,
uh,
Caitlyn Jenner,
all the Kardashians.
Um,
just everything that he does it fuck is bill Maher's.
Ridiculous.
And then he got like all these different Trump's,
he's got tiny Trump,
trans Trump,
just Trump in general.
Um,
it's fucking unbelievable.
so check that out.
So anyways,
um,
we ended up going,
walking over to the,
uh,
we ended up over at the Fillmore,
so we go to walk in,
you know,
and there's a band playing.
So of course the security like,
hey,
whoa,
Whoa,
hey,
whoa.
We like,
yeah,
hey,
we're just going in there to get a drink.
And the guy goes,
uh,
you can't,
it's a show going on.
This is a concert venue.
You know,
I taped a special,
there was kind of funny.
I said,
yeah,
I know.
I gotta go.
I've performed here because,
oh,
you've performed here.
I've never done this.
I just said,
yeah,
I'm a comedian.
I just want to go on and have a drink.
And then fortunately,
he recognized me and I was able to pull that fucking card.
I never pulled a car.
It's pretty cool.
So then I went upstairs and I just hear this fucking woman's voice.
You just incredible playing the guitar.
Incredible.
And I poked my head into the seat and you know those big tour buses,
Shit.
But there wasn't a band on stage.
It was just,
you know,
you know when the one person's up there and their play into a loop and then they
loop it with something else,
the Pr,
you know,
she was doing that shit.
I was like,
aw man,
I missed seeing bands.
I get it all the fucking crowd stole the music and the fucking labels do the
cross the board
fucking deals where they even take a piece of your merge,
you know,
the greedy [inaudible] so I get it.
So it was just like,
yeah.
So it's kind of bumped out even though her voice was fucking incredible.
It's just like,
I like watching a live band cause I like when I want to bands like improvising
and shit.
I always love watching like Stevie Ray Vaughan cause she'd see Tommy and uh,
Chris Layton,
well never stopped looking at them cause they're like,
all right,
what's he doing?
Is he going to go around again or is he going to fucking go into the verse?
You know,
when,
you know,
when it start to come to the point where he would come out of the Solo,
is he going to keep soloing?
What is he going to do?
And when you just see that and then you see Stevie just give them like this
fucking little nod is he's wailing on the guitar and then they just seamlessly
in that moment know that,
that go into this next set.
That's what I fucking love.
Um,
so it's just one person up there.
It's,
you know,
but you here in a band,
I get,
you know,
I'm a fucking old guy on man.
Where's the rest of the people?
Right.
So I walked into the other Roman,
I was sitting there with Nate,
you know,
and I'm just listening to this woman singing.
I'm like,
oh my God,
she's fucking unreal.
I'm here a little Amy Winehouse.
So just using incredible and uh,
I had a drink or something and I go,
man,
that's,
I swear to God,
that sounds like a band.
And then I walked back out there and now there's a whole band on stage and I'm
like,
where the fuck did that woman go?
Was she opening like what the fuck was going on?
Long Story Short,
I find out it wasn't a woman who was a guy and his name is Alan Stone and that
was one of the fucking best voices I've ever heard in my life.
Incredible Guitar player.
Let me see the name of the band.
Um,
it was funny,
we went in,
there was like a,
like all these hardcore fans of this band is called Andrew Andrew McMahon in the
wilderness.
Now granted this isn't like my necessarily my style of music that I would listen
to,
but like how well these people sang was just,
it was fucking incredible.
The Piano player was cracking me up because he was dressed like Kenny Loggins
and like the early eighties,
I like if you looked at the guy,
like that guy is going to have a major cocaine problem.
Yeah.
Like the Kenny Loggins beard.
And then he had the sweater tied around his neck.
Um,
like when I came up in the 80s,
anytime they were going to have like an asshole in a fucking coming of age movie
in the 80s,
they always had the sweater tied around him,
you know,
if the fucking frat boy or whatever.
But anyways,
but it was a completely different vibe.
And afterwards,
all these nerdy chicks for going out and talking to,
I look at my face,
can you tell I was crying.
They were crying.
There was definitely,
I don't know what was going on,
but it was definitely sort of the crowd was those,
you know,
the kids who can't throw a ball,
and aren't good at fighting.
It was that group of people.
Um,
and they will fucking end to this band.
And this band was fucking amazing.
Fucking amazing.
But what was hilarious was the bartenders were all bored as shit because none of
them were drinking.
The Fillmore has this really long bar that goes all the way down the left side.
And these fucking bartenders would just leaning with their backs against,
you know,
where the cash registers.
That shit where with this looks on their faces,
like how the fuck did I get this shift?
Not gonna make any fucking money tonight.
But anyways,
um,
if you get a chance to see them live,
uh,
or ever get a chance to see that Alan Stone,
I just was looking him up and he was singing with a Daryl hall and stuff.
Evidently the guys is like fucking legendary.
And I'm going like,
who is this chick?
Why?
Where's the rest of the band?
And I just walk in the other room.
So fucking stupid.
But I'm glad that I was able to,
uh,
cause I was talking with people afterwards when they leave and I go,
Whoa,
where was that woman?
And they will laugh and go on.
That wasn't a woman that was a guy that was a guy.
Thanks.
Allen's down.
God.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
so I went up when I saw that there was a whole bad,
like I've,
you know,
I've only been in the film or a couple times and um,
when you're upstairs you get,
you know,
unless you have like the two old guys in the muppet show seats in those things,
it's very hard to see the band.
But then this is one area where it's straight on.
So upstairs,
so I walk and there was this woman's security sit down.
I go,
is it okay to walk over there?
And she goes through that section is private
and I want it to be like,
I only asked you once,
you fucking cunt.
I don't know if she was yelling over the music,
but I was just like,
what the f I felt like I was on like a seven year relationship with there and
whatever the fuck it is that I,
I do that bugs her.
I just did it.
That section has private,
ugh.
You know what I thought about,
you know who is that guy used to climb in to the ring like a spider.
The Guy who kicked the guy and broke his leg in half.
Um,
Anderson Silva.
I remember that front kick he would do and you just didn't see it coming,
you know,
that went into my head when she leaned forward.
Private just give you the old right there Fred.
You know,
and I would do that as an empowering move to a woman.
treating her as an equal like,
well that's what you would do to a guy.
Right.
How come women don't want that part of equal rights?
It's all right.
You want to make what we make them.
You know,
you gotta take a mid to the face every once in awhile.
By the way,
I have been such an asshole on stage this week.
I've been having such a good time.
I said some of the most ridiculous shit.
Um,
I don't know that I've said,
I don't think ever.
I've just been like,
it's a total reaction to like what the f all this fucking crap out there.
You know,
I did this interview recently and I was talking to this guy.
I'll probably get in trouble for this shit.
I came here,
what the fuck are you talking about with the guy goes,
yeah,
but you can't say they can't see.
It's like,
what the fuck are you?
I yes,
I can.
You can't say why.
Why did people all of a sudden won't know they're jokes and then then there'll
be,
yeah,
what's going on?
What the fuck is going to happen?
Um,
so anyways,
I been up here all this week and um,
I got this thing in my write up,
but if I spend more than one night someplace,
they'll bring in some old drum kit or whatever and I just play on it during the
day.
So,
uh,
I'm up here and I don't know that one of the guys who,
works at the theater is a drummer.
They get me these sick fucking DW kit.
That sounds amazing.
I brought my double pedal up and I brought my fucking that all that music that I
wrote out on that a Metallica song you spent having like the best fucking time
ever,
although I'm missing my wife and my kid big time.
But this really is a,
an amazing city.
And I had a friend of mine come out last night,
uh,
where I hadn't seen in awhile and I kind of learned some shit though.
I was glad that we hung out there rather than over at the punchline because I
really like how my brain works as far as when I get depressed is when I tried to
go into the past.
You know,
like if you go into a place that you haven't been in a long time,
like you're all excited and then you walk in there and like,
nobody that,
you know,
you don't know anybody anymore and you're like that,
ah,
fuck,
I'm old.
The time came and it went,
why didn't I enjoy it more?
You know?
So I was glad I met her over there.
But uh,
you know,
she just was one of the people,
I don't know that it should have been a person like her and every comedy town
because she fucking her tastes and comedians and how much she gave,
there's still gives a shit about comedy is,
I think one of the major reasons why the standup scene here has always been so
freaking strong.
So anyways,
let's,
uh,
let's plow ahead.
I went to the giants game yesterday.
The,
uh,
the baseball giants,
they had a day game fucking started at like one o'clock and I'm,
Nate was giving me all this shit because I was keeping score.
When I go to baseball games,
I like to keep score cause if,
if I don't,
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
You know,
there's literally 18 people,
you know,
you don't know how many who's given up hits in the eye,
yellowy,
make a pitching change and you don't even hear it.
Cause there's so much fucking shit going on.
You know,
at the giants they have this woman doing the fucking announcements and like
their voice just,
it just doesn't carry like,
I don't know what it is.
Like you need the base to cut through.
He's eyeing Aviat a man he has.
Yes,
he has yet.
I'm like,
what the fuck did she say?
Then I have to look at the number and then I gotta look it up on my phone.
It's like you just announced it over a PA system.
How the fuck did I not hear it?
Um,
I played drums.
Maybe my ears are fucked up.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what,
but um,
I got a $12 cores at that fucking ballpark.
And what's funny is when you get the scorecard,
the scorecard is a dollar and then they make you pay for the pencil.
Now the pencils,
a buck,
it's like the cheapest thing in the park and got a bag of peanuts and had an ice
cold beer.
I sat there keeping schools fucking great.
Only thing I was missing was a cigar would have been perfect.
And I'm this fucking Guy Suarez.
Got Sheldon the first dating and then he settled down.
But the giants were never able to catch up.
It was,
you know,
it's a good game.
Stephanie.
Good game,
beautiful ballpark.
The reds got some guy on the,
on their uh,
their team,
little fella and he goes by scooter.
So like I'd be like,
you know,
at some point you've got to call me by my name,
but he still goes by scooter.
Right?
So we're sitting there going like,
Nate's going,
how tall do you think that guy is?
I'm like,
that guy might be a couple inches shorter than me.
And then he steps up to the plate and just fucking crushes one crushes one all
the way out to the fucking,
I call it the ocean.
We're Covey's bay cove.
Sorry,
I'm a Covey's cove.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Um,
I think that's why he still goes by scooter,
cause that's got a really fuck with the other PR,
the pitchers,
you know,
confidence and you just step up to the plate.
You name's Mike and you go yard.
He's not going to give a fuck with some guy named scooter hits the ball into the
fuck.
You know,
your best pitch into the fucking ocean.
That's,
you know,
you've gotta be,
you've gotta take a lap around the mountain going like,
is this the end of my career?
Some fucking make a wish kid just came up and just fucking crushed into the
ocean.
Um,
anyways,
how bout those Boston Celtics,
once again,
I'll work in every fucking night.
This week,
I've missed every second of the last series in this series.
I just keep watching the highlights and um,
and defense,
the Cavaliers,
uhh,
I guess they have the worst team defense in the league.
Um,
but you know,
Brad Stevens I guess is out coaching them and all that stuff.
But,
uh,
I gotta be honest with you,
I really won't feel comfortable that we're going to beat the cavs until we win
the fourth game.
Cause if the Cavs went tonight,
I'm assuming the plane tonight that all of a sudden it's two one and he just
gets scary again.
Like,
Oh fuck,
here comes the Lebron he had comes Lebron.
And when you're talking about a guy who has led his teams to the finals,
how many years in a row,
and I don't give a fuck that he was on a pile on team.
Coby was on a pile on team his entire fucking career and he didn't go to the
finals fucking,
you know,
seven years in a row,
whatever the hell
yeah,
Lebron is working on right now.
So,
uh,
we shall see this is all,
you know,
it's all gravy.
But they just keep putting it in the fucking rocket speed.
The goddamn warriors last night,
I guess,
which is incredible.
Um,
you just can't root for the warriors.
Once Duran went to the warriors,
you just can't fucking,
it's the stupidest,
it's so fucking stupid.
It makes the Miami Heat not look like a pile on team.
I am.
Maybe he was a pilot.
I,
but I'm just saying,
you know what I mean?
Oh,
Z NBA was so,
I know I've said this a thousand times,
but the NBA was so fucking great,
that warriors thunder series.
We're thunder when up three games to one and then they fucked it up because they
were too young.
They didn't know how to win.
And the warriors showed the championship part that they had.
And then that was the story.
The next year
was where the thunder going to fucking get over the hump,
where they going to dig down deep and,
and,
and slay the fucking dragon.
And what happens
Luke Skywalker?
It goes,
you know what?
You are my father.
I'll fucking join the dark side and fucking Kevin Duran just goes over there.
And the second he went over there,
everybody who watches NBA hoop goes,
oh,
the warriors are going to win the championship.
And then they did.
It was fucking boring as shit.
Um,
the only thing I like about it
is that Duran didn't go to the Lakers and I have to watch them,
you know,
once again,
free agent their way to yet another fucking championship,
which admittedly is a Celtics fan.
We did in 2008 but the fucking,
you know,
I've watched the Lakers get five championships in the last like 20 years doing
shit like that and it's just,
you know,
gets fucking tired after a while,
um,
especially because,
you know,
according to them,
their one championship behind us,
which,
you know,
we all know through Bill Simmons Book Than Not that too.
And we also know that it was a mobbed up fucking ref that fixed that Sacramento
series.
So they got fucking two banners,
you know.
But uh,
what I do like about it is that's very la to pad your resume,
you know,
to make Instagram videos and then call yourself a director.
Um,
anyways,
so I am a,
I dunno,
we'll see what happens.
I wish I could just watch one of these fucking games.
If we get by the Cavaliers
and the war is,
you know,
of course they're going to go to the fucking finals.
How are they not going to want a championship when you have like every fucking
good guy in the league is on your Goddamn team.
Um,
I mean,
I dunno,
the Celtics actually could win one or two games against the fucking warriors.
I'm them.
I'm not looking ahead here.
I mean,
that'd be what I'm really on there.
We got Kyrie Irving free agent guy right there.
Bill fucking hypocrite.
Um,
yeah,
but we're upstart too.
Those are all fun.
Get off fucking everybody adds one free fucking agent,
right?
That's all I'm saying.
It was just,
it was just bad.
I just don't understand why,
you know,
I fucking hate the Lakers,
but I don't understand why that one guy couldn't go to the fucking Lakers.
But Kevin Durant could go to the fucking gold stay away.
Did you kill you?
Kill the whole fucking story.
It'd be like if when the Celtics beat the Lakers in 84 if magic said fuck it,
he just joined the Celtics.
I Dunno,
whatever.
I'm an old guy.
The Celtic signed free agents too,
but let me,
I,
I would,
I would think if we went to make a move like that,
um,
someone was actually saying that,
you know,
Duran or somebody is up for free agency and he might go to the Celtics and I was
thinking,
I don't fucking want that guy.
I don't want to be become part of the problem.
You're just going to bounce around the league.
No
picking up rings on it,
you know?
And this is from a guy who barely watches the NBA.
Why am I this subset?
I'll tell you why I'm the subset now that I asked the question for you guys,
now I'm going to answer it.
I just remember when I was at,
when you were,
when you were a fucking kid and you had outdoor recess and you would choose an
up teams even as little kids,
if it got too lopsided,
you'd be like,
oh wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
He didn't even it out because even then you knew like where would the
satisfaction be in winning
kids know,
kids know not to do what the fuck they're doing.
But I mean that is the way it's done now.
I mean,
free agency give,
I should just accept the fact,
okay,
here's,
here's the deal.
I accept the fact that this free agents,
okay.
And I admit the Celtics,
you know,
we bought a championship in 2008 and uh,
and we also added Kyrie Irving this year,
but you know,
maybe,
you know,
okay.
And Lebron could get along a little better.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't fucking know,
but
yeah,
they asked it should,
that should be aligned,
you know,
that that Miami heat things shouldn't have fucking happened.
The,
the,
the uh,
what's his face trade?
Kevin Garnett with Kevin Mchale on the front office,
gives his old team Kevin Garnett for nothing that should have been blocked,
would pog saw with Jerry West and the front office went to Lakers.
That should have been blocked.
Just shit like that.
That's all I'm saying.
C.
So I took a little burden out there,
you know,
maybe I don't fucking know any who gives a fuck.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
what do I got here?
I got two more goddamn show.
You have no reads.
I have no reeds here on Thursday.
And I'm trying desperately not to do my impression of countdown against Donald
Trump or fucking bill Maher to his bill Maher is so fucking ridiculously on.
Have you ever seen the one he does?
Um,
where are you?
She has like Bill Maher reading to children.
He's stringing reading like nursery rhymes.
He's like,
hey dude,
I'll doodle the cat and the fiddle.
Okay.
The cow jumped over the moon.
Really over the moon.
This story is bullshit.
And he just like makes the kids cry.
I know I'm doing a shit version.
You got to hear the guy stop listening my podcast and go hear some real comedy
at,
at Kyle Dunnigan.
One.
The guy's a fucking genius.
I don't get how that guy is not on Saturday night life.
I just don't.
Yeah,
you know,
I,
I bet you know why?
Cause they wouldn't do the Caitlyn Jenner Shit.
I Dunno what happened.
They,
they're all fucking political over there now.
That used to be rebellious,
you know,
you got to see is Kaitlyn Janice.
Shit baby Trump.
All right,
I'm done hyping it.
I don't want to fucking overhype I can over hype but it's fucking hilarious.
Alright,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
so I got,
what's the night Thursday?
I've got two more shows up here and then that's the end.
Um,
I'm going to be just doing a bunch of sets around La,
get ready for 'em my,
my big shows there in uh,
in Europe and then my big birthday turning 50 next fucking month.
You know,
I don't feel any different.
My shoulders fucking great.
Here's the deal.
Every year on my birthday I got to do like,
uh,
the amount of pushups for whatever year I am and I haven't done them
the last couple of years cause my shoulders but fucked up.
So I think the last time I did was I turned 47.
So,
uh,
I'm up to doing sets of 35,
so I'm right on right on pace here.
And maybe then turning 50 won't be as devastating.
But I did 50 pushups.
Does that make me a mortal?
Um,
anyways,
you know what?
I think we'll have the podcast is going to be a little short.
I mean,
I don't think I have anything else to talk about me.
How the fuck am I going to fill up these?
I feel,
I don't even know why.
I mean self employed.
Why do,
why do I feel,
what am I going to fire myself if I know to a full half hour?
Is that what it's going to be at?
You know,
the Red Sox are actually playing the Oakland A's.
I was thinking of going over there like an asshole.
You know what I did here in the San Francisco is joking.
I did the impossible.
I actually got a fucking sunburned in San Francisco like the sun was out,
but I was just like,
it's San Francisco.
It's always cold and shitty here.
Um,
they just have miserable fucking weather.
that,
you know,
they have the great white shark fucking weather.
Right?
The water's freezing.
No one ever made it off the rock man.
Right.
It's just always like that.
In fact,
I used to always come here and every time I would come here I'd get sick.
Um,
I dunno why it was like the flight from new,
I was living in New York and every time I'd come out to do the punchline I would
get sick because a I way I wasn't taking care of myself than I had that extra
long flight.
And then I would step off into this just cold,
damp,
fucking awful weather.
And like three times in a row when I came here,
I got sick.
And um,
Molly at the punchline,
I remember the last time I came out there,
she sent me like fucking
sent me all these vitamins c packages,
which is fucking drinking a zillion of them before he got out there.
So I would get sick.
I starting to think I was allergic to this town.
So when I uh,
looked,
you know,
I looked up the fucking weather coming up here as I was waiting for it to pop
up.
I just said cold and shitty.
And I looked at it and it was everyday there was clouds with a little bit of
Sun.
And then rain and I don't know what happened.
Something changed.
So yesterday we,
uh,
we walked over to the ballpark and
I'm like,
God,
this is going to burn off.
This is going to burn off.
A bought a couple of really good seats.
And uh,
I was just sitting in the sun the whole fucking time wearing a north face
jacket,
sweating my ass off.
But I was like,
well I can't take this off cause I got on short sleeves underneath that I'm
going to fucking burn up.
So I sat there and a winter coat and like 75 degree weather keeping score.
I looked like a fucking,
you know,
the only thing I was missing was those giant headphones with like the am radio
antenna sticking out of it.
Um,
those are the fucking lunatics though.
Like I wasn't that bad of a nerd.
You know,
those guys who actually listened to the ballgame while they're watching it and
they're keeping score.
Um,
but I'll tell you,
they know everything that's going on.
They know when they make a pitching change,
when there's a pinch hitter and all of that shit,
like trying to keep score like when you're out in the outfield.
The only way I was able to do it cause I was uh,
and um,
right behind home plate.
So when somebody came up on on deck,
I would just check the number to make sure they didn't switch somebody out.
Um,
and that's my exciting story about keeping score.
All right,
I'm finished.
I'm starving.
I'm going to go.
I've been eating good even though I've been drinking again,
which I don't fucking like,
but I just get,
I get fucking bored when I'm out here.
What am I going to do?
You don't want to fuck me up.
Was I brought my reset a stone up here.
I brought the little external fucking distinct that you stick it in.
I plug it in and I left the fucking desk at home.
So now what am I supposed to do?
Am I supposed to get some food coloring book?
My show is at seven every night.
I'm done by nine.
I'm all wound up.
You know,
I've seen more goddamn couples arguing in public up here.
The city is more expensive,
I guess,
than even New York City for rent or to buy something.
And you can really see the stress on the people just screaming at each other.
So that three times yesterday,
and I'll tell you the woman was winning all three
and each one of the relationships,
I was like,
she's a lot smarter than that guy.
Why is she with this person?
Okay.
Cause like the guy was like trying to come back,
you know?
Oh the rocky Balboa.
What about you?
Whoa,
whoa.
And the woman would just rattling off all the things that this guy was fucking
up.
And granted I was just walking by,
you know,
by experience,
their relationship for five seconds.
And my immediate thought other than these two people need to break up was uh,
you know,
she,
she's got you there buddy.
She's making a lot of good points.
Yeah.
And I,
but joking about this on stage to San Francisco has the most homeless homeless
people I've ever seen in my life.
Yeah.
It's almost like they're not real.
They're so fucking homeless,
this skid row,
it's just fucking,
it's unbelievable.
We walked by this woman,
she was literally passed out in her hand,
was on the ground and there was an empty bottle of booze that like,
so artistically had just rolled like,
like two and a half inches away from her hand.
It looked like you were on you.
Yeah.
Like you were on the set of a movie about homeless people like that.
That's just such a perfect shot.
You know about alcoholism and addiction and all of that type of shit.
But it's like real
okay.
Yeah,
we will like walking home from the park,
trying to avoid the hills,
you know,
as much as we could.
And we just got into this,
this,
it was like,
you know,
everybody's got their skid row.
They have a neighborhood,
just a fucking navy,
just walking through,
you know,
I saw this fucking guy,
he's in a wheelchair when these guys in a wheelchair,
but his legs work,
whatever the fuck that deal is,
you know.
And,
uh,
he just had like his shirt pulled up over his face and then his hands,
like covering his face,
like he was the saddest person on the planet.
You know,
I was walking over the Fillmore and this is blind guy just asking people,
somebody can help them cross the street.
So I was like,
all right,
I'm going that way,
you know?
And then he grabs my arm and then I immediately put my hand on my wallet because
it's like,
all right,
I know I'm a gullible white guy,
but I'm not that fucking dumb.
All right?
So I go to step off the curb and he goes,
wait,
wait.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
you're right.
It's fucking green.
And then I'm looking at him like,
and I start laughing like,
how the fuck did you know that that light was great?
Yeah.
Okay.
And he started laughing.
I forget what the fuck.
I guess it makes a noise or some shit like that,
but I almost walked a blind guy.
He goes,
you've got to watch out for the buses.
Yeah.
I almost walked a blind guy right it right into the fucking bus.
Um,
so I'm a fucking liberal SAP,
you know,
this woman says to me,
can you give me blah,
blah,
blah?
She look all sad and she,
I don't know,
something way she fucking asked me.
I was like,
ah,
give us some money.
And I said,
Nate,
you think she's drinking?
And he goes,
yeah.
And I was,
I was like,
all right,
forget it.
I won't fucking,
and he goes,
okay,
if you want to go buy her a sandwich,
I'll fucking do that.
And I was like,
all right.
All right.
You know.
Well,
maybe she needs some fucking boots.
I got a phone call.
Oh,
look who it is.
Local.
It is an old friend of the podcast.
Joe To Rosa.
Joe,
I got you on speaker.
Yeah,
recording right now.
I'm Ricardo.
Wrapping up.
Joe.
Joe,
remember we used to do one in form?
Remember we used to
what up kid?
Yeah.
When are we ever going to do another episode of Eddie thing?
Uh,
no,
I gotta tell Ya.
Hey across the country have asked the same question and
was that plural or was it just,
was that one fan or did you actually say fans?
There was a fan,
at least one guy in every city asked the same question.
Yeah.
After,
after I opened,
people ask me all the time,
nope,
no bullshit after I opened for you.
And uh,
what was the ladder?
Shitload of people came up to me after the show outside.
They were like,
what are you doing on in forum?
I was like,
dude,
I want to,
I,
I just,
uh,
it's hard,
you know,
you know what's fucking hilarious about all of this shit,
Joe,
if I jumped in my car,
how quickly would I get to your apartment?
Okay.
No traffic
with no traffic.
Yeah.
[inaudible] I got a whole set up over here.
Let's just do one.
Yeah.
Joe,
I gotta be honest with you.
I have the weirdest relationship with you out of all of my friends because we
never had a falling out.
But how little we see each other and how close we live together.
It's like we had a out,
I don't know what happened.
What happened to us,
Joe.
So we tran,
we transcended into family territory.
I consider you family at this point and you know,
you see,
you don't see your family though.
I mean,
honestly,
dude,
I look at you as family.
I'm like,
yeah,
you know,
we're,
we're good.
We're going to hate of family back east.
Um,
all right,
well I think there's a reason why you called.
So I guess we could,
we got to do something.
We got it.
At least I got to have you on the podcast as a guest.
Is there anything you want to promote Joe?
Uh,
Bill,
I have a podcast of my own and I will see you with hell.
That's hard move.
Ah,
Joe.
Oh,
it's okay.
It's about that.
It's like Jesus,
Joe,
he said it's about horror movies.
Sorry,
I talked over here.
She could check that out.
And I'm at the old San Jose,
a rooster teeth feathers at the end of the month here the last week of May.
Ah,
you're going to shake your ass up there in northern California.
Yeah.
Shaken my fucking tail feathers.
Making you money.
All right,
let me,
and this fucking podcast,
hang on one second.
All right.
And then I'll,
I'll talk to you about what other bullshit you want to talk about it,
right?
Hey,
by the way,
no,
not,
wait.
No.
Stay on for say,
Hey,
have you gone to [inaudible]?
Have you been on cal done against Instagram page.
Oh,
done against.
No,
dude,
it's,
it's the funniest shit.
[inaudible] you have to go on it.
It's some of the funniest shit I've seen on the fucking Internet.
I'm not threatening your job.
I'm just saying you got to do it.
All right.
Let me wrap up this podcast.
Don't fucking hang up cause you won't pick up.
You know,
you never pick up unless it's a broad there.
Um,
all right.
That's,
that's the Thursday afternoon podcasts.
I gotta talk to my,
uh,
my fucking stepbrother,
Joe to Rosa here.
Enjoy the music.
And uh,
the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
greatest hits that will follow here.
All right,
I'll check in on you on Monday.
You cards.
Okay.
[inaudible]
I bought
a microphone.
Am I do like when I'm out here,
I literally had to a rule about just relaxing when I drive.
And one thing that it helped,
it's very therapeutic for me is letting people go.
If you're really like,
I get so frustrated with the quality of the driving out here at the inability to
fucking make turns at a decent speed and do when they go buy shit out here,
the second they pass it,
it's it.
They don't even remember it.
They have no fears,
no fucking clue as to what's behind you.
Like you know what they do here out here.
That fucking drives me.
Now you'll be sitting behind some guy at a red light,
you know,
and you're up on his bumper.
You know,
like you're supposed to be not in crazy and it's the light turns green.
He then puts his,
uh,
left fucking directly
Chanel absolute enraging and it's self centered and yet it's,
it's,
I'm with you.
It's so wrong that I fantasize about pushing him into traffic and know it's
wrong.
You don't have the moral courage to do it.
That's totally,
I think that's totally right and whenever you hear about somebody getting shot
and killed for road rage,
everyone folks goes,
all my God,
that maniac that shot,
that person and I honest to God,
the first thing I think is I'm glad like until I find out that guy with the gun
was the Dick,
right?
Who fucked up first.
I love that you have to find out that the guy with the gun was a dick.
I know to to find that out.
We'll find out.
The guy with the gun overreacted a little,
but it just,
there's something about,
because people are so self centered and narcissistic when they drive it,
it's a reflection of who they really are.
So that's why we take it so fucking personally may like you let people go.
If the guy,
if a guy doesn't wave,
thank you to me that don't do that apart.
And Lil sin,
they don't do that out here.
And I go from like being this fucking mother Theresa Person.
I turned into the devil.
It starts,
I try to stay calm as such,
with a couple of release and my car.
I just got really,
really real.
You're not going to fuck these fucking people out here.
I don't know what the fuck you get a little down before I ended up turning into
that just because some Douche dude,
you see the look on their face,
they're like,
please,
please let me go.
And you'd go to let them go and you think like,
Oh hey,
thumbs up something.
Nothing.
They immediately,
I just back into their own.
Uh hmm.
I Dunno.
I find sometimes I wave at people out here and they look at me like weird.
Like,
what do you know me?
Like I maybe,
you know,
I did move 2,500 miles away from where I learned,
societal rules.
So maybe,
uh,
but you know,
you just think if you know,
you're waving to another white guy.
I mean,
we were pretty fucking generic.
Yeah.
You know,
if there's not a lot of
depth of the culture here,
there's no gang signs right away.
I can see black guys.
He's a little freaked out watching between your fingers at her.
Well plus east coast though is is so aggressive and I hate to do like an la
thing but out here maybe that courtesy like in Boston or New York if someone
lets you cut it and it's like,
Hey motherfucker,
I did you occur to seeing,
okay,
thank you for the courtesy that you're a good shit though.
Welcome,
you're welcome.
But here it's like whoa.
That was just expected because they might do that for each other more out here.
It's not a big deal.
That's the only I can think of.
I was on the Pennsylvania turnpike one time driving to a Gig and I know I'm
popping all over.
I'm very self conscious talking.
No you don't.
You don't get much credit it,
but I don't,
I don't have anybody to help us out with this.
Okay.
I was a
driving to a Gig and the guy cut into my lane and I was doing about 70 it was
raining and he had a trailer
normal.
And I'm like,
it was a rear wheel drive to with my Mustang,
real hunker,
shit,
fucking hydrocodone cognitive call and I'm driving and this guy's coming into my
lane and I immediately,
your mind when you think you're going to die,
it goes very quickly.
And I'm like,
okay,
you got to slam on the brakes,
you're going to have an accident.
Hit the wall.
Like it tried to it.
Yeah,
that's smart.
slow,
slow yourself down.
Sideswiped the wall.
So like jam on the brake.
I hit the horn and he veers out and we don't have the accident.
So then I'm not afraid.
I'm in a rage at this fucking guy.
Right.
And I pull up next to them and it's a,
it's a,
you know,
I have a fat black dude,
like you know,
family mopey guy and I'm ready to really,
you know Cleveland from family guy.
He's actually,
yes,
William Stephenson fellows of the college
and he looks at me and he gives me the like,
oops,
I fucked
dup.
Wave like up,
sorry.
And it gives me that and every bit of anger drinks cause he,
he,
he just owned up to it.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
I way back.
No problem.
Yeah,
that was that in a second my rage,
I was gone.
Do you know,
it's funny,
I sometimes when somebody acts on the rage,
even though I know it's wrong,
I sort of lived through the,
the fucking ecstasy that that must be like,
do you remember when Russell Crowe through the phone?
I said,
Guy,
I just can't imagine like when you're in a hotel and you're not getting the
customer service you want on whatever it is that the fact that you actually take
the machine that they won't help you with and fucking hurt somebody,
the person who is not helping you,
you fucking hurt him with it.
Yeah,
completely wrong thing to do.
But I can't imagine.
I always was wondering why.
Cause he's letting that phone go.
Just,
Ah,
just fucking all that rage going at him.
I think it was,
it was good for him,
was bad for the guy behind the,
uh,
behind the counter.
Behind the counter was bout people.
We'll learn the lesson that day.
Russell Crowe learned not to do it.
The other guy probably learn better fucking customer service next time because I
remember when that happened I was in the Greenwich Hotel and I wish Deniro owns
and I remember like,
Oh my God,
that's a really nice place.
It's beautiful.
Like he would stay at a dive when a stupid comment,
but I remember things
in the satisfaction.
It must've felt when the phone hit the guy,
like how good that must have felt a throw that phone with that motherfucker.
And again,
he got in big trouble for that.
But yeah,
that was just is a story
that I do.
You know how mad you are,
you're,
you're pulling the wires out of the wall and that voice is still not going,
okay,
what are you doing doing?
What are you doing?
And then you wrap it up,
you leave your hotel,
you're walking down the hall.
He leave your room,
you get into the fucking elevator and your brain's still going.
Yeah.
Throw it at him.
Throw it out.
What happened?
Well,
I mean he,
he went downstairs to the front.
I mean,
I don't,
I was just going to pick the phone up off the desk and just threw them.
Oh,
I thought he was upstairs in his room.
Maybe he was,
but I thought that I didn't,
I didn't,
I thought he just picked the phone up and threw it at the guy.
That makes way more sense if I find out that he actually wrapped the court and
took the phone from downstairs.
That makes me love him more.
I was,
I loved him just for picking it up.
Probably fucked it up.
I fucked up everything.
I don't know.
Do you know the other day I actually called the periodic chart?
I called it the periodical.
This,
yeah,
but that's the understanding.
I mean,
once it was on breaking bad,
it's no excuse.
It's like you're on a,
you're on a western,
you call it a cowboy.
You had,
how do you not fucking know?
It shows you the amount of fucking research I did.
[inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and this is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 17th,
2010.
How the hell are you?
How are you doing?
How's your work?
We'd go,
I,
yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
I just,
uh,
this is one of these days,
right?
Where I should,
I shouldn't,
you know something,
I'm gonna start having tap out days where I don't do the fucking podcast because
I just got off a goddamn flight and I am fucking exhausted.
Once again,
I flew across this goddamn country and once again it was the usual shit,
you know?
And I don't want to make fun of people who are out of shape because they've got
a really heartfelt letter from somebody who was opie saying,
what the fuck?
Why you always trash in fat people?
Which I'm not.
That's all you're hearing because that's the one that pulls on your
heartstrings.
You know,
when he writes the whole fucking thing about how blah,
blah,
blue,
blue Gaddy,
Yada,
all this fucking Shit,
you know,
everybody feels,
everybody,
whatever group they're in,
they feel like they get it the worst.
You know,
we get it the worst,
you know,
even Blahblahblah when they blue blue,
blue people lease sake again,
right?
But when they say,
fuck,
I know,
please.
All right,
everybody thinks they got it the worst and only one person is right.
Okay.
So you've got like a fucking 85% chance of being wrong.
You know,
nobody says,
uh,
you know,
I'm going to beat you like an obese stepchild.
Do they?
They don't.
They say on a beach,
you're like a red headed stepchild.
They don't have kick a fat Guy Day,
do they?
They have kick a fucking redhead day,
a Ginger Day,
right?
That's what they have.
Mia did make a fucking video about,
uh,
the,
the fucking genocide of obese people.
Did she?
No,
she didn't.
She made it a red heads and it was funny.
Even on me.
I've been so beaten down as a fucking red head.
All right?
So quit your fucking whining.
You know,
it's a fucking podcast.
I trash everybody.
Everybody's going down,
including myself.
Everybody goes down this week,
okay?
If my Bruins are going to lose four games in a fucking row,
and I got to listen to Keith Robinson,
okay?
A guy who my entire time of knowing them,
every time I tried to bring up hockey goes,
ah,
hawkish sticks.
I don't like it.
Nobody cares about hockey.
All of a sudden he gives a fuck.
You know what's funny about that?
Fucking ignorant.
Jacquez he wouldn't even have known that the Bruins had a historical collapse
of,
you know,
I'm so stupid of historical proportions.
He wouldn't even have known.
It's just that ESPN finally showed some fucking hockey.
Jesus Christ.
I was in Boston when it happened and I really want to tell Philly people that
everybody was devastated.
But I gotta be honest with you,
I think maybe 11% of the city gave a shit.
And I'll tell you why,
because we haven't won in 38 fucking years.
And we've pretty much sucked.
Um,
the Bruins kind of jumped the shark when Ray Borg had to leave the team so he'd
have an opportunity to win.
And then he went out to Colorado one the cup and then I know he will,
he meant this in a good way.
He brought the cup to the city to remind everybody in Boston what it look like.
Yeah.
And that was the low point,
you know,
that was a low point.
And then we were up three games to one against the Canadians and we couldn't
close them out.
We lost that fucking series.
Then they blew up the team when they traded away.
Gone Chad and fucking Joe door and dude,
fuck them.
The couple of queers they leaders do.
So we trade away our best fucking guys for what?
Who Do we get?
We got a fucking a baby face Magoo.
Well,
we ended up trading to fucking Toronto.
That's the only thing I got.
I got right now we've got the number one pick,
fulfill fucking castle.
That's all I got right now.
But um,
anyways,
uh,
I don't know what happened in that series.
All of a sudden they just stay,
just fucking sucked.
It wasn't like they weren't even trying,
they weren't even fucking truck.
They were just standing there going,
wow,
look at the fliers.
Jesus Christ.
God,
that Guy Skate.
Oh,
hang on a second.
I'm going to try to clear it out of the zone.
And the guy would take a slap shot at,
he couldn't get,
he couldn't even clear it out of the fucking zone.
It would go like sideways into the boards.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
That fucking Mac Davis looking jackass,
Hartnell,
whatever the fuck his name is.
He was funny about Hartnell is after the game when he's not,
when he's not wearing a helmet,
he looks like a scary son of a bitch,
like Jesus Christ,
that that guy just come out of the woods,
you know,
does does,
does,
you know he fucking,
he just see,
just looks like,
I don't know what he looks like.
He looks like a mountain man.
He puts said that helmet on.
All of a sudden he looks like he's in blades of glory,
you know,
and he fucking guy can't even skate every
return.
He goes and make a pass,
he falls down.
But the fuckers there though,
tapping it in
Ganni,
Brie air,
all those fucking assholes.
Congratulations Philly.
You guys totally deserve it.
Uh,
you know,
unlike the Bruins,
you didn't quit.
He kept playing the game.
Yeah.
Dot.
I don't know what happened that she,
the Bruins play the game right through game four and they played the first
period of game seven and a little bit of the third period.
You know,
and I know this sounds like I'm taking away from the flyers,
but dude,
they were just standing there and they had one line that would actually go out
and start checking some of the fliers.
And when they did,
all of a sudden we were getting,
we would get an opportunities.
It's like,
why wouldn't you continue doing that?
Was,
is that crazy?
Yet another job,
Craig,
he had on the bench.
Did he also sent to the bench go,
oh yeah guys,
by the way,
don't forget to play hockey when you're out there.
And uh,
when they're,
when they're around our net and they have the puck,
it's usually a good thing to try to,
you know,
disrupt them.
Trying to put it into the net rather than just standing there and waiting for
them to shoot it in the neck into the net so you then can whack your stick on
the ice and frustration.
Oh jeepers,
they did it again.
Golly,
Gee,
Gee Wiz.
I was fucking brutal.
Is Bad enough.
I had to sit there and watch the Bruins lose,
but I was in Boston,
which means,
and this is a great thing,
uh,
about fucking being in Boston is you guys know how I feel about Dan Shaughnessy.
Okay.
The Guy,
he knows baseball,
I'll give,
you know,
I will give him that.
But other than that,
he has made a fucking career on misery.
The guy loves misery.
There's any fucking misery to be found.
And I give a fuck if somebody's playing highligh or stick ball,
he's going to be there to write a fucking story.
And the great thing is,
is he doesn't have the decency to know a God damn thing about the sport.
All he's gotta do is just talk about this misery that's about ready to happen or
is happening and then somehow tie it in to fucking game.
Six of the 1986 red sox met series.
That's what the fuck he did with hockey.
If anybody who lives in Boston still has,
I was going to grab one of the Globes,
Boston gloves.
It's fucking hilarious.
I was saying at the night when we lost and I was in a bar with like eight other
people,
was more fucking flat screens on than there were fucking Bruins fans at that
point.
Right.
Typical of all cities
at do it.
That meant diehard it midday.
Everybody's fucking die when they win a championship,
all of a sudden when they shit the bed,
four games in a row,
you're not doing a credit to the Celtics cut into the Celtics course.
You are.
You like a winner,
don't Ya.
Um,
but I was lily stand there going,
you watch this guy,
he'll somehow to do,
you know,
he'll bring it around to the curse of the bay,
which of course he does.
And the great thing is,
is he does not know shit about hockey.
All he did was he looked at the box score to see who scored when just so he
could be,
and it's 1748 of the second period when a fucking hot and I'll shot the puck in
the net then.
So he could then be like,
uh,
it was quieter in the,
in the garden than it was in Fenway back and fucking puppet with Mookie Wilson.
He,
I,
you guys are the worst.
He's the fucking worse.
And he's got,
he just,
I dunno,
I just don't understand how that guy still has a job and why people in Boston
continue to buy his books about fucking misery.
Yeah.
You know,
he's such a pussy.
Anytime anything remotely bad starts to happen in Boston sports,
he always got,
oh my God,
what's gonna Happen?
It's,
it's really,
is that how you fucking approach,
you know,
whatever the fucking word is for adversity,
adversity,
that's the word.
That's how you approach it.
It isn't,
you wouldn't have gotten to the level that you're at as a sports writer and
being on ESPN if that's how you approach adversity.
So stop to eat and don't use your fucking lazy.
Learn about the Goddamn gay before you write another one year lazy ass fucking
articles.
Dan Shaughnessy,
do you want to see what this guy looks like?
I'll tell you right now,
just go,
go to fucking uh,
the EMM podcast.com.
Get on my nice fucking photo.
Put up with him this week.
That noodle hair looking jackass.
Do you know,
I remember like a year after the red sox,
after they came back being down four games to none,
you know,
not against some sad sack fucking team that barely met,
made the Goddamn play offs.
It doesn't have a fucking score.
They came back against a 210 to one a million dollar fucking team with like four
or five first ballot hall of famers.
We go on and and,
and when the God damn world series,
the very next year in September we got a couple of injuries.
We had like a six or seven game lead against the Yankees and all of a sudden the
Yankees come on and we start to lose a little bit and this fucking idiot writes,
the curse is back.
You can feel it.
It's back.
It's in the water.
You know,
it's the curse of what Dan of course of what?
2004 the the what of the fucking let 11 month curse.
The curse of what that,
that no one wants to buy your stupid fucking book about misery.
Is that what it is?
I Dunno.
I gotta admit.
I think that was the worst part about the Bruins losing four games in a row
cause for the fucking life on me.
I still don't hate the flyers.
I actually like Carsello I really like them and I hate the fucking Canadians.
I hate the Canadians in of a flyer fan gave me shit.
I Made I,
I sit there and take it Canadian fit gave me shit.
I'm not going to take it cause I'll tell ya the end of the fucking day,
that flyer fed,
he's from the United States.
That's a fellow countryman.
So all he's gonna do is trashed the Bruins.
He's not going to trash the good old USA.
That's why I don't like to convey this.
Why I hate the Canadians fans of most.
They fucking trashed my team and my country.
I'll tell you right now,
I won't stand for it with their little pointy little French noses.
They appointed a little French noses.
Huh?
Talking about yesteryear.
I'll walk around with that high school fucking Letterman jackets up on how they
used to dominate the league 30 fucking years ago.
Let me tell you some right now Canadians,
you guys can fucking slide all over the ice block and as many shots as you like
cause you goaltender actually sucks these any fucking good.
Why you guys flopping around like a bunch of goddamn flounders every time
someone takes a fucking wrist shot,
oh my God,
whatever.
Am I really trashing teams that are still in it?
I'm going to shut the fuck up now.
What am I going to do?
Okay.
What goes around comes around.
I've talked a lot of shit.
My teams have won a bunch of championships.
We deserve some sort of,
you know,
it's the balance,
Dan Shaughnessy.
It's the balance,
okay?
He can't win all those fucking championships in five years and not expect to get
kicked in the seeds as a sports fan.
All right?
But do me a fucking favor.
Don't write any more articles about hockey because you don't know a fucking
thing about it with your glancing at the box score,
curse to the Bay Horse Shit that you wrote,
okay?
They should surround this.
What they should do with all those globe though,
debt piece of shit article he wrote,
they should snip it all out.
Tie Him to a stake and use that as a stuff that you use to start a fire.
Whatever that word is.
What does that word come on?
Help me out here that we're to use when you stoke a fire with something gives
with a k,
doesn't it kill in a kit,
Caitlin or cut something?
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Jesus Christ.
I don't,
you know,
if you gave me a three games to none lead with like fucking six of my friends,
I used to play pond hockey with,
we could have one,
one fucking game.
Jesus Christ
just fucking standing around,
standing around.
Then they went up three games,
three goals to none in game seven.
Then all of a sudden they score the flyers score one goal,
and then they go back to that pussy hockey again.
Oh my God,
he's good to go.
Do you think they're gonna score another one?
It was.
It was pathetic.
And uh,
I dunno,
I am ashamed.
I'm ashamed.
I'm ashamed of my team,
but I still love him and I'm still wearing my bro and shit.
I don't give a fuck.
You know who gives a fuck lose three games in a row?
Four games in a row.
Yeah.
Why would you give a shit?
You know?
You know,
I know.
I like how these idiots are sitting there talking about hockey right now,
going like,
you know,
and it's wide open this year.
It's fucking wide open.
You know,
they've the number one seat to seat to seat and unforeseen is fucking got.
Yeah.
That's because the two teams that are left beat those teams.
Stupid.
All right,
well actually no,
the Bruins beat the fucking third seat,
whatever.
I'm just saying.
And all of a sudden people are looking at the Canadians like a,
they'd like add still in eighth seed team.
They are still an AFC team but you know,
they'd beat the capitals and the penguins.
So I would have to think that they are odds on favorite to win it.
And um,
I know this is boring the shit out of everybody.
I've literally talked about hockey for 15 fucking minutes.
Have I?
Ah,
fuck you guys.
I don't give a shit.
All right.
In this next round I am for the Black Hawks and I am for and uh,
I am for the flyers.
My nightmare finals obviously is the Canadians for San Jose because I hate both
of those teams.
I respect San Jose.
I went there there actually it's a hockey town.
They fucking loved that team,
even though,
even though they fucking choke every year,
but I got to,
I just don't like how they,
you know,
they annoy me.
Yeah.
San Jose.
And they annoy me because they remind me of how annoying my French Omaha,
how my franchise never fucking signs anybody.
And they somehow sign everybody in there in and under the fucking cap.
But,
uh,
I gotta go for the Black Hawks because they haven't won it since 61 and a,
so I'm pulling for that team and uh,
and then I got a pull for the flyers because,
uh,
I dunno,
I actually always have liked the flyers.
I have to admit I always liked him.
I liked the fights back in the fucking day.
Oh.
And speaking of that,
I remember that shit before the series started,
they got this new show on,
on the versus network,
this round table of like for regular dudes.
And then we'll have like some big sports star.
Come on.
I'm not saying if it's a good show,
a bad show,
but I saw somebody on,
I believe it was that show go in like a Bruins verse.
Flyers.
Oh God,
this is going to be a bloodbath.
Okay.
Just for the fucking record for people who don't fucking watch hockey,
it's not 1979 anymore.
All right.
And the Bruins,
it flyers just played seven games,
seven games I believe.
Two of which that went into overtime.
I'm already trying to block the whole memory,
that series out and there wasn't one fucking fight.
There wasn't even at any cheap shot.
There was,
I can't remember.
I've,
I don't,
wasn't mean I wasn't really paying attention with the Bruins.
Enema went one point.
Mac Davis there got,
got to stick to his face best cause the dude was trying to lift the stick up and
he missed it.
You know,
we've got a couple of fucking stitches.
Yeah.
Ah,
fuck it.
All right.
That's it there.
I addressed it.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
whatever.
I heard there's a really good guy in the draft next year.
Taylor Hawkins.
Is that his name or is that the drummer from the foo fighters?
I can't fucking remember.
I don't know any of that shit.
I'm just hoping,
look,
this is all I wanted.
All I wanted was us to fucking a,
after we beat the,
the,
uh,
the fucking savers,
just to have a good showing in the next round eight when we fucking lose.
I don't care.
I know we're rebuilding,
but did you have to shit the bed to that fucking level?
All right.
Whatever.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
This is a,
a,
a special hockey edition of the,
uh,
the Monday morning podcast.
Um,
all right.
I don't even know where the fuck to go from here.
Uh,
how about a youtube video?
I,
I might've even hyped this thing last week.
Uh,
this is one of these things.
Um,
uh,
just search this.
Don't fall asleep at a baseball game.
Just watch that.
And uh,
for all you women out there,
you'll realize how much fun it is to be a guy when you watch this video.
Like,
we can have fun when there's absolutely nothing going on.
And not only that,
it's fucking hilarious.
Are you saying that we can't have fun?
Actually,
I think I kind of am,
but I think the reality is,
is I just don't understand your fun.
So I want this,
this fall.
You all the ladies out there.
Uh,
why don't you watch that video.
Okay.
And,
uh,
I challenge you not to fucking laugh.
Well,
I guess you won't,
you won't laugh.
You guys are great liars and your greater controlling your fucking emotion.
So you want,
but I'm just telling you it's a funny fucking video.
All right,
now you,
and,
and if you want to show me how women have fun,
you show me a video of women doing like absolutely nothing is going on,
but it's still fucking hilarious.
Find one of those on youtube and I'll have a little more respect for whatever it
is that you do because my references are,
I guess,
uh,
sex in the city.
You know?
Is that even a reference?
I don't know.
Just the women I've dated,
I've always watched that fucking show,
you know?
Can you believe that I'm making another fucking one of those movies they make
and another sex and the city movie and now they're going to Egypt.
At what point are they just going to let that fucking thing die?
Why don't they just have the cast of the drew Carey show show up and that's what
they should do.
And then turn it into colleague Leah and somebody gets fisted and then just
fucking ended.
Can somebody just end?
This really has nothing to do with either one of those franchises.
It has to do with my fucking jet lag and uh,
and the Bruins complete fucking collapse.
Okay.
Yeah.
Fuck it hurts.
Uh,
Jesus.
All right.
You know,
I drank a lot this past week.
Um,
this is,
I realized something.
This is a big test in a relationship.
I don't give a fuck how beautiful you think a woman is,
how much you love her,
how much she makes her heart go pitter patter your heart.
Go pitter patter.
The,
the true test of whether or not you can stand.
You're going to be able to stand the woman that you think you're going to spend
the rest of your life with is if you can handle what her voice sounds like when
she's trying to yell over the noise in a bar.
If you can handle what that sounds like
and you just fill in your funny punchline right there because evidently I don't
have the fucking energy to do it.
Whatever.
I just talked for hockey for 17 minutes to my fucking self.
I trashed Dan Shaughnessy.
I told the fat guy to stand down.
You know fucking people want sympathy cause they always eat the last cookie
rally.
Selfoss sons of bitches.
Um,
alright.
You know what I'm going to do this week?
I'm going to tap out by reading some fucking emails from some of my listeners.
Oh,
here's something I learned this week.
Did you know that the natural color of rubber is white?
Did you know that?
I didn't know that went by this guy's place.
He had this collection of fucking cars and old motorcycles and I love that shit
cause I wish I was good at working on cars.
You know what I mean?
I wish I had like a set set of wrenches and anyone working on a car,
you know,
greasy rag and my back pocket,
I could fucking,
you know,
find that right spot and the jukebox and make it play a song,
you know?
But I can't,
you know,
I killed that.
You know what?
Fuck you.
I could,
if I took some time,
I watched a couple youtube videos and he gave me a regular old engine.
I could do some shit.
I could figure out some stuff maybe in another life.
I don't know what.
So anyways,
this guy had an old motorcycle guy.
I like how it's got at the,
you know,
I'll wait tires on it.
And he goes,
that's actually,
cause it was like,
uh,
one of the original motorcycles,
I guess,
where you couldn't even fucking stop the thing.
It just had to run out of gas.
You just turned it on and it just went full on.
And I guess the way to slow it down was you had to reach down and put your hand
over,
uh,
the carburetor or something.
Whatever the fuck.
Yeah.
With the air goes in the old,
is that what happens?
Oxygen and gas mixture.
He just put it over there.
You sort of smothered it and that's how you slowed it down.
But anyways,
these tires,
I know that's completely wrong.
So you fucking gear heads can trash man.
I don't give a fuck.
You doing a podcast,
you've got a podcast on how the original motorcycles run.
I didn't think you did.
So go fuck yourself.
All right.
Once you clean out under your nails so your wife doesn't get another fucking
infection,
that was brutal.
Um,
anyways,
when your finger blaster,
just to spell it out to the fucking nerds in the cubicles,
um,
how do I know that?
I forget how I know that I overheard a fucking dirty broad talking about that in
a bar one night.
Anyways.
Yeah,
I guess the original color of of rubber and its natural color is white.
I didn't know that.
So all these years when I was looking at white wall tires,
I thought that they just took like a strip of white paint or whatever and they
painted them white and the natural color of rubber was black
but it is white and you would think I would have noticed,
you know all the years of looking at cars that side swiped curbs,
you know,
and hacking up their tires.
It was always white underneath.
You'd think that I would have noticed but I never did.
So here's my question for all your gear heads out there.
Why did they paint it black?
You know
anybody,
I don't know.
Fucking know.
Where am I going with this shit.
You know what that actually reminds me of?
You ever see like when somebody dies on a bicycle and then they have that entire
ghost white bicycle that they have there,
that creepy one with the flowers.
I saw another one.
It absolutely gives me fucking chills.
It's my closest sixth sense moment that I'll ever have in my life.
When they do that,
I don't for the fucking life of me understand why they have to put the bike
there too.
You just can't put a reef down.
Why do they have to do the whole bike?
What is,
who started that?
I know I talked about this on the and Anthony show a couple of years ago,
but what the fuck?
It's still bugs me.
It just creeps me out that,
you know,
he was on a bike and he died.
They don't have like drunk drivers,
you know,
they smash into trees or you get hit by a drunk driver.
Do they frost out a fucking car,
you know,
with a mannequin underneath it.
I,
that's a brutal job and I,
you know what I mean?
It's just fucking creepy.
Fucking creepy.
Stop it.
Some of you know,
gets hit on a bicycle.
Leave a wreath.
They're like a normal person.
Fucking sit there.
Why don't you just put the bike?
He got hit on with a bent up tires and shit.
I knew it was going to be mean this week.
I'm tired and I'm fucking,
my Bruins lost four in a row.
All right,
let me,
uh,
try and get something positive here.
I'm literally in mayday,
mayday right now.
All right.
Hi,
Bill.
My fiance and,
and a couple of our friends saw you in Atlantic city this past Saturday.
You will be on hysterical.
I got a picture with you,
but Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
I recently quit my job as a photo retoucher for this high end retouching company
by my job was to make models thinner and more beautiful,
but also sit on my ass 10 to 12 hours per day,
like a robot.
It was brutal.
But what could help me through it was listening to your Monday morning podcast.
I would sit there in a silent room hysterically laughing,
often needing to throw my headphones off because I was crying.
I was laughing so hard.
In fact,
they got in trouble once for laughing so much.
I needed to be more and people told me I needed to be more serious about my job
for thanks.
So thanks for doing what you do.
Uh,
well thank you.
I don't know why.
I saved that podcast,
but that email made me feel good.
And you know what,
I saved that before the Bruins lost four games at a fucking row.
So I was,
I was in a better mood.
Yeah.
All right,
let's read another one and see if I can get out of this.
I'm a really,
really bombing right now.
Ah,
Bill.
Hi.
I love your work.
I don't know if you've covered this before,
uh,
as I found out about you.
Ah,
ah,
but what are your views on celebrity adoption?
I think I saw Sandra Bullock's,
uh,
has just done this,
but to be honest,
she doesn't have the profile or in or indeed now the father figure to really
pull off this adoption.
Seriously though.
I think it's sick.
They find the most fashionably deprived countries,
countries.
Oh my God.
I can't even read this week too.
All right bill,
come on.
Come on.
Get your shit together.
Right.
They find the most fashionably deprived countries.
Uh,
that doesn't even make sense.
Do you mean the most popular ones to give a fuck about?
Is that what you mean?
They take the prettiest kid in the orphanage and then dress them up at the baby
gap and carry them around like a fucking Chihuahua.
It's like by absorbing them into this plastic la bullshit lifestyle,
they pretend they're actually doing something about the root cause of global
poverty.
When Angelina Jolie adopts a 56 year old Serbian war widow with a drinking
problem,
takes her to Disney world and lets her fuck Brad Pitt,
I might then buy it.
All right.
That's all hilarious.
Even though I didn't read it correctly.
But,
um,
you know,
this is just this classic thing where do you ever notice when you do something
good?
If people find out about it,
they have to trash it on some level.
I mean,
you know,
I get what you're saying.
I've actually done bits about that.
Uh,
you know,
that they,
I actually did something about Paris Hilton,
something bedazzleing some out African kid make are making the kid match her
phone or something like that.
And she left it behind in a club was one of those topical jokes I don't think I
ever did on TV.
But,
uh,
she is kind of doing something about pocket.
You say she's not doing something about poverty.
She just took a kid who was in poverty.
All right,
I'm going to play the devil's advocate.
Okay.
And put him in a fucking house with running water and is now going to feed them.
You know,
I think a lot of times when people do good shit like this,
it annoys people because it reminds us that we're not doing shit about it.
Maybe that's why I make fun of them.
Or maybe it's that thing,
you know,
heathens pray in public so everybody can see our fucking holy there.
I don't understand why they can't just adopt the kid personally and just fucking
do it and then that's it.
You don't hold it up on the cover of people magazine.
Look,
now I'm agreeing with you.
I'm going to go a little skitzo on this one.
Yeah.
Sandra,
why do you get to hold the fucking thing up?
You know,
I don't fucking know,
but she is doing something about poverty.
That kid was fucking broke.
And I'm really sick of all you people who don't live in Los Angeles talking
about how plastic La is,
and then you're acting like nobody lies in nobody's full of shit in your fucking
hometown.
Just be honest.
They're better looking than you.
They have more money than you.
Okay.
And they're living the life that you fantasize about.
All right.
I'm man enough to admit that I was actually mad enough to move out here and have
the audacity to think that I could live that life on some level.
That's helper fucking pathetic.
I am.
Um,
look,
I gotta be honest with you.
If I ever did something like that,
I think it's a great thing to do.
You know,
I,
you know,
and considering the world is fucking overpopulated and where we're headed
towards major food shortages that nobody wants to deal with because everybody's,
you know,
I haven't had a boy yet,
so I'm going to try to have another kid,
or I haven't had a girl yet.
Someone tried to have another kid.
You know,
I read something about this guy in rolling stone today.
I ain't know his fucking name,
but he's some legendary soul singer that I've never heard of.
So I don't think he's at legendary cause I think it would have heard about him.
I think when you're like,
seriously,
well I guess if he was an icon,
I would've heard about them.
Whatever.
I'll give it to him.
He's legendary.
The fucking guy had 21 kids who then spawned 90 grandchildren.
Um,
and you know,
I'm going to fucking call it first in the future.
That's going to be fucking considered illegal.
Like what that guy did is basically he had his own major fucking oil spill into
the ocean,
but rather than the ocean,
it was on land.
You know,
his fucking seaman
would just fucking leaking out 5,000 gallons of fucking day,
just like that goddamn crater.
The bottom of the ocean.
You think he didn't just on a couple of ducks making 21 fucking kids.
They did.
That guy should be in fucking jail for that 21 fucking kids.
I mean,
you guys are at work.
Can you name 21 people you work with?
Can you imagine if that was your fucking kid?
21 kids.
He has 90 grandchildren.
There's no,
do you understand?
He doesn't know the names of all of his grandchildren.
Well,
maybe he does,
but in order to make room for that,
you'd have to forget half of your friends' names.
I know the names of 90 people with the fuck.
I probably know the names of 90 professional athletes.
I'm really underestimating the power of the human brain.
But what the fuck
one fucking guy's dick with two balls is far as we know,
created that,
that fucking ecological disaster.
You know what I love about rolling stone is,
is,
is they actually got in,
in that,
um,
in this week's issue where they have Keith Richards on the cover yet again,
you've got to love rolling stone every fucking three weeks.
If they're not,
just have some teeny bopper on there.
They're still mining the 60s.
The exile on Main Street reissue,
I love this shit were like,
the original artists were like back in the day were just like,
do you want to release this song now?
It sucks compared to the rest of the shit.
And then 40 fucking years later when you want to buy another yacht,
you start putting out shit that you didn't feel was worthy of releasing when you
were at your peak.
Okay.
You know,
I don't fucking know that Tupac Shit that Jimi Hendrix Shit,
the fucking,
uh,
I don't know.
There's very few that I can think of that they actually reissued that were
actually worth listening to.
I'll tell you one in recent years,
this past decade was led Zeppelin when they came out with that concert film of
them at Royal Albert Hall.
And um,
okay.
You know,
all that concert footage.
That shit was great.
That actually
was great stuff.
But they,
but they also weren't wow.
You guys,
red led Zeppelin is repackaged.
They act for them.
What the fuck am I talking about?
Every two years they,
they,
they have whatever,
10 years they do the new digital remaster of whole lot of love.
You know what I mean?
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Talk about rolling stone.
Okay.
So getting back to that shit,
they actually do a story on this guy who's like,
um,
he goes into like,
you know,
war torn countries,
any like buys up land and he makes deals with basically war criminals or,
or whatever to buy up land because he knows that this unbelievable like,
um,
yeah,
food crisis is common.
It's fucking scary.
And this guy's out there having 21 goddamn kids who then go on to have 90
fucking grandchildren and uh,
you know,
it's the kind of shit that,
that like,
that's it.
Morning Talk,
show stuff,
you know,
like nobody would even even sit there and talk about how fucking reprehensible
that is.
I don't know.
Look,
I think I should get a tax break at my fucking age.
All right.
I had to be able to drive a full size fucking hummer with no muffler down the
Goddamn street.
The fact that I have not procreated and,
and just basically,
you know,
right now I'm,
I'm basically doing what people,
yeah.
Uh,
related to Hitler or doing,
I'm letting my bloodline die off
if you guys ever heard of that shit.
Yeah.
Then evidently the relatives of a,
you know,
like his fucking great Greg grand nephews or whatever or whatever the fuck they
are.
There's evidently like two or three more left.
They live in Long Island and they all made a pact not get married and uh,
and just let the bloodline die off because they're so afraid that whatever made
Hitler so fucked up,
we'll let,
I mean they talking like some omen shit.
Okay.
You know,
like you'd be pushing your little baby Hitler on a swing and all of a sudden
your nanny's standing on a rooftop,
you know,
jumping off because like,
subliminally this little fucking kid told them to,
with this fucked up cute prepubescent prepubescent mustache.
Yeah.
I fucking hate this podcast.
I really would erase this thing if I wasn't 35 fucking minutes.
And I really would.
I really would,
but I can't because I can't,
I can't go through this fucking shit again.
I can't read this stuff.
All right.
Well anyway,
you know,
I can't remember what my fucking point was.
Look,
I think Sandra Bullock did a good thing.
Okay.
Uh,
why she did it.
I don't fucking know.
Okay.
But I'm going to give her the benefit of doubt that she did a good thing.
But just notice anytime anybody does something,
even remotely consider it.
Like how fucked up that makes people around him.
Yeah.
At no point did Sandra Bullock go,
I did this.
You should do this to look what a great person I am.
Granted,
she's holding the fucking kid up like a Goddamn bowling trophy on people
magazine.
You know what?
You're fucking right.
But I kind of relate to her because,
yeah,
like when people find out,
I,
when I first bought my Prius,
I got a ton of shit from people.
What'd you do that for?
Who Do you think you think you were actually making a difference?
You know,
like they got all fucking defensive.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm not saying you can't drive with the fuck you drive.
I bought it from me.
I fly every other fucking weekend.
I put my own hole in the fucking ozone layer.
I'm trying to do something.
Yeah.
Something you know,
to not be a total douche.
Right.
That's all I'm doing here.
I'm not saying you're doing anything wrong.
I'm not saying you can't drive a fucking car with a v eight.
I'll give a fuck what you do.
Get in your car and get away from me fucking asshole.
Um,
I dunno.
So that's what I have to say about that.
I don't know if it made any sense.
I don't know.
I got no idea.
Alright.
Right.
Here we go,
Bill Burr.
Well,
what do you want to ask me?
Ask Bill.
Um,
oh,
here's one for you.
I got it right here.
This is the one that's going to pull this fucking podcast out of the goddamn mud
bill.
I'm 21 years old and attend a big 10 university.
I'm not the best looking guy in the world,
but I think I'm,
what I lack in that department is made up with high amounts of intelligence and
charm.
Wow.
You just really sound like a sweaty fat guy with a lampshade on his head.
But I'm not going to judge.
Um,
that's another fat guy joke.
Maybe I do have something with,
I dunno.
Yeah.
You know what it is because I'm constantly in contact with those fucking people
to Goddamn epidemic out there.
You know,
I had the ILC and uh,
I was back towards the back of the plane today and you know,
the aisle seats great.
You could stretch out a little bit when you want to get up and take a leak,
you don't have to step off of people.
There's a lot of fucking advantages to have in a,
but when you start getting towards the back of the plane and then becomes that
moment where everybody has to go to the bathroom and aligned develops.
The problem is,
is as these round people are trying to get past each other,
there's not enough room.
So what ends up happening is one of these douchebags stomach slash unit ends up
on your shoulder as they lean a little bit into your fucking airspace so the
other fatty can get by him.
It's fucking guy was enormous.
So the Goddamn plane to the point I felt like heat coming off of him.
Do you want to stand like how out of shape that is?
It was like,
okay.
You know,
you could like,
like earth,
the planet,
fucking earth.
How the CCO,
it's core is still on fire.
Yeah.
All right.
I didn't,
I really didn't want to attack fat people get,
I know I'm going to lay off.
I'm going to lay off for the rest of the podcast.
That's it.
God bless you.
I know.
It's a problem.
I'm ruined for you.
Do the right thing and have a salad.
I got my problems still got me.
Yeah.
You know,
whatever.
All right,
here we go.
Uh,
anyways,
you fucking try to get through this.
All right.
I'm not the best looking guy,
but oh boy.
Can I tell a joke?
I'm not just patting myself on the back there.
Uh,
there is a reason I'm stating it all right.
For the past two years,
I've been doing horribly in school.
Oh,
Jesus.
And I just trashed,
this guy's going to fucking kill himself.
I've been doing horribly in school dealing with things that are pretty
depressing.
But because of this,
I've had to come up with clever ways of trying to pass classes in an effort to
not get dropped from school.
Uh,
as such,
my strategy has been to pick,
uh,
teaching assistants that are females in order to try and charm my way into
passing the classes while putting in as little work as possible as I possibly
could do.
Do you have a future?
I'm gonna tell you this right now,
son.
Don't give up on yourself.
Do you have a fucking future?
If you've figured out a way to pass classes by doing that charming people while
doing little or no work,
I'm telling you there was a corner office waiting for you,
so don't,
don't give up on yourself.
All right,
here we go.
What the fuck am I?
Uh,
but EPA,
Dha a little work as possible.
Granted,
I am well aware that manipulating slash charming women into giving me good
grades is fucked up and not the most practical way of going about doing things,
but it fucking works.
Hey Dude,
they do that.
To get a free drink out of you.
You don't don't,
there's no shame in that fight.
Fire with fire.
I'm totally with this guy.
However,
my lack of foresight is very much evident now is something you probably saw
coming happened.
I fell hard for my ta,
this,
the teaching assistant this semester from day one.
I was attracted to her.
This is a good story so far.
How could this go off the rails?
Um,
let's continue.
And a while I do try and charm her.
Every chance I get in an odd way,
me being so attracted to to her has fueled my motivation to study and show off
the fact that I can easily ace or class.
I go every week to her
office hours.
I go to [inaudible],
I go every week to her office hours she holds for students,
which are about two hours and nobody ever goes.
So it ends up just being her and me flirting with one another the entire time.
However,
maybe it's uh,
because I'm a male or maybe it's because I'm so attracted to her,
but I didn't notice the huge wedding ring on her finger.
Oh geesh.
A,
we go,
everybody,
it's going this way again.
A lot of guys out there fucking do on a wrong turn.
All right?
But I didn't notice her huge wedding ring on her finger up until about a month
ago.
Uh,
I bet in a class now for about four months.
I brought it up to her saying,
Holy Shit,
you're married.
And her response is what holds my hopes.
Okay?
Before I get into her response,
dude,
you're full of shit.
There's no way for four fucking months you didn't notice her,
her fucking wedding ring.
This is you toning down the fact that you knew right out of the gate.
She was fucking married.
She had a huge wedding ring.
He didn't,
you didn't notice.
Okay,
maybe you're young,
maybe you don't look.
But how do you miss that?
And then you said,
Holy Shit,
you're,
you're married.
That sounds like a great setup line to get the response that you got.
So the guy says,
Holy Shit,
you're married,
Huh?
And she goes,
he goes in a response is what holds up my hopes in an astonish almost forgetful
way.
She replies.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
Okay Dude,
you're in.
All right.
I'm not saying you should do it,
but if your,
if your question is,
am I in,
you are in,
mmm.
Since this revelation I have been continuing to bring up,
uh,
as much as I can about her husband.
If nothing else for comparison.
All right.
This is getting twisted.
Dude.
Don't bring up her husband.
Just go in if you've got a bang or just fucking Banger,
you know.
Does he look good?
Better in a jacket that I do or do I look better?
The more I bring it up though,
the more it seems like she regrets getting married at such a young age.
She got married at 23 and now she's 25.
This is my predicament.
My parents got divorced when I was six because my bald,
childish fat piece of Shit.
Father cheated on my mother with their best friend.
So I have reservations about dating a married woman.
Uh,
doesn't sound that horrible while I'm trying to justify.
Yeah,
it doesn't sound that horrible.
While I'm trying to justify attempting to date a married woman.
But it's like you said,
what is it?
75% of marriages go right down the shitter right now.
I have no problem with waiting it out.
But I'll ask my question in two forms.
One,
what would you suggest doing to try and feel out the likelihood of this marriage
lasting?
And two,
if it's clear that it's not,
which with not much prying done on my part is clear to see it won't.
What can I do to perhaps bring about the breakup as soon as possible?
All right,
dude,
these are the questions of a 21 year old.
Okay?
First of all,
you don't date a married woman,
all right?
You want to bang her,
go ahead and bang her.
She actually wants you to bang her because she needs some sort of spark to get
up her courage to get out of that fucking marriage that she clearly didn't want
to be.
And um,
I'm telling you right now,
as,
as she was walking down the aisle,
her brain was screaming,
what the fuck are you doing?
All right.
This is,
uh,
you know,
she got married at 23.
I don't know what our dating experience was before that.
Maybe she doesn't know how to get out of it.
She seems like someone who does not know how to get out of a relationship now
what kind of relationship she has.
It doesn't sound like an abusive one.
It sounds like a,
I don't know.
She just got involved in something and then she just got into deep.
Didn't know how to get out of it.
That do what?
It met a family.
When are you getting married?
And she just fucking went down that fucking water slide.
She did not get off.
And now this is her deal.
So this is the deal,
dude.
You're going about this the wrong way.
I,
first of all,
you shouldn't fucking do it.
All right?
You shouldn't do it because you're,
you're,
you're dealing with the married fucking woman here.
There's somebody who wanted to spend the rest of his life with her.
All right?
And you're delving into that shit so you don't,
and you,
oh,
I'll tell you right now,
do you don't know what this girl's going to do,
okay?
She could be using you for the courage,
right?
Go out and fucking bang you all right now god damn rainstorm come home like a
drown fucking rat,
just so he can start the conversation and be like,
honey,
where the fuck have you been?
So she can just flip out and be like,
I just fucked one.
Am I students?
You know,
just so she could just get out.
Whatever.
How many fucking years she's been sitting on?
I don't want to be with you anymore.
All right?
And I'm telling you,
if you,
if you meet a psycho fucking woman,
they have a really bad fucking habit of doing something really fucked up with
the person that they're in a relationship with.
And then they feel guilty afterwards so they have to confess.
And then,
you know,
the guy can't hit the woman.
So guess who he's going to come and hit.
You know that you just blew up his fucking life.
So you shouldn't fuck this girl.
But I'm telling you right now,
dude,
if you're going to bang her just fucking Banger,
but you wanting to date a married fucking woman is completely the wrong fucking
thing to do.
I like I just gave you the green light to go ahead and bang her if you want,
you know?
Okay.
I mean,
I'm not telling you to do that,
but I'm telling if you're gonna choose one or the other,
he got three choices.
Don't fuck her.
That's what I'm telling you to do.
All right?
But if you're going to go with Defi,
going to go to the dark side,
there's Darth Vader and this Darth Vader light here.
Okay?
And I'm saying to,
to take the less calories of evil here,
what you should do is just try to bang out.
Do not try to date this girl,
okay?
This girl wasn't ready to date.
She doesn't know what the fuck she wants.
She shall she sold,
doesn't know what she wants and she show has so has an inability to communicate
what it is that she wants,
that she actually married somebody she doesn't want to be married to.
She's just sitting there with its screaming inside.
I don't want to maybe married to you.
I don't want to be married.
I don't even married at this point in my life.
I don't want to have kids.
I'm not ready for this.
I want to get the fuck outta here.
I want to,
I want,
you know what she needs to do.
She's bring up at this guy and go get an apartment and live by herself for a
good year and a half,
two fucking years,
you know,
and not really date anybody for a good six fucking months.
Cry this shit out.
Go to therapy,
figure out what's wrong with her.
Make a fucking list of what she wants in life.
She's got to do shit.
She needs to do that kind of work.
And you're trying to date this woman,
this fucking mess while she's still married.
Don't do it.
All right.
Go charmed the shit out of somebody else and try and bang them.
I'm telling you right now,
dude,
don't fucking do it.
Don't do it.
All right.
That's my advice to you.
Uh,
that's it.
That's it.
That's all I gotta say on that.
Don't,
don't fucking banger.
And if you do decide to Banger,
I mean you do decide to get with a do not fucking data,
okay?
Even,
even if I'm telling you,
dude,
you're gonna fucking probably make the wrong decision because you're young,
you're probably going to try and data cause you actually got feelings for all
right?
And then what she's gonna do is she's just going to use you to get over this
other guy before she dumps you and fucking rips your heart out of your goddamn
chest.
That's what the,
you're going to be roadkill.
All right?
Fortunately you haven't banged her yet.
You know,
all he got his feelings for.
So get out now.
Dial it down a sir class.
Get on with your fucking life.
There's plenty of other fucking teachers' assistants out there that you can bang
,
all right?
But that's,
that's not the move to make good luck to you.
It's your life.
You make your decisions.
But I'm telling you over and over again,
evidently I'm going to keep saying the same thing over and over again.
Do not cease and desist.
Fuck that.
Walk away.
Walk or do you know what?
You don't want that on your resume.
You just don't.
All right.
Trust me.
Okay,
here we go.
Ask Bill.
Uh,
this story is a little bit long.
Um,
but,
uh,
I was out with the clothes.
Oh,
Jesus.
Here's another one.
Oh,
Jesus.
Um,
the story's a bit long,
but in the end of your podcast,
but in the end,
oh,
this is this fist that actually an interesting one here.
Okay,
Bill,
this story's a bit long,
but in the end,
your podcast makes a girl cry.
Okay?
Somehow my podcast made a girl cry.
Okay,
here we go.
And I was out with a close and his girlfriend,
his girlfriend,
having some drinks and a five bottles of wine later,
my friends girl brings up a point about how pro athletes are overpaid.
I said a yes,
it is dumb to pay someone $8 million to catch a football.
But if you think about everything else,
it's,
it is deserved.
First off,
millions of people play plan there every Sunday around watching these athletes.
And since the industry is a gold mine for the owners,
the talent gets paid a pretty fair portion.
Secondly,
virtually every man in America,
his played organized sports at some point in their lives.
I think it's fair that you are,
if you are the absolute best,
it's something that every man has tried to do in their lives.
You should get paid.
Um,
this isn't the high score and that arcade game and your favorite pub.
Every man in America has put,
put some quarters in this,
in this one.
I don't know.
I think that was some of that left out or they just read that bad.
Anyway,
so I'm from that,
it quickly turned into an argument about the fact that pro women don't get paid
that much.
And that's where I bowed out.
I stopped and said,
Oh,
you're one of those girls.
I'm sorry,
but this conversation never goes well of Jesus.
Dude.
You're totally Batan or for a fight.
I love this guy.
Okay.
Uh,
she snapped back and said,
no,
no.
Say what you're gonna say now.
Come on.
You brought it up.
Fucking say it.
She didn't say all that,
but I know she did.
So he goes,
honestly,
I tried to avoid the issue.
No,
you didn't.
You baited her into it by saying,
Oh,
you're one of those girls.
I'm sorry,
but this conversation never goes.
Well,
a classic.
What do they call that?
We had you fucking you.
You do the reverse sell.
Yeah.
You don't want a car like this.
Then the,
the,
the guy actually sells it himself.
Um,
oh,
there's my dog.
Cleo,
come over here.
Cleo.
Odo what's going on?
I just picked her up.
She was staying down at the dog.
He Super Eight.
Look at you.
They gave you a little high top fade.
Then you trimmed underneath the belly.
Huh?
What's up buddy?
You got anything to say?
Weak little exhale into the microphone.
All right,
here we go.
I fucking hate with a dog.
Does that
Lick my fucking toe?
It's weird.
It's creepy fucking moment that you're not happen between an animal and a human
being.
All right.
I'm continuing on.
Yes.
He basically,
you baited this one to a fight,
dude.
You know you did.
I know you did and I love you for it.
I think it's great.
I love arguing with women like this too.
So anyways,
let's continue on and I'm not buying your shit.
Honestly.
I tried to back out,
but she said,
say what you're going to say.
So he goes,
honestly,
I tried to avoid the issue.
Uh,
I did.
I will say that I am a bit of a massage.
A misogynist.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
Dude.
Okay.
I had no idea.
Uh,
but I know,
uh,
what not to get into feminists.
Um,
plus she's my friend's girl.
Ah,
this is getting ugly and you're drinking just can not end well.
But she forced me into the argument after she heard me say,
after she heard me say to my friend,
why am I arguing with the girl about sports?
Dude,
you'll be totally passive aggressive.
That's hilarious.
Let me guess.
You said it like three feet from her ear.
Why am I arguing with the girl about sports?
I mean,
they don't know shit about sports.
You know,
how did they just make me a sandwich?
And then they fucking,
they come back at you and you and you act like,
you know,
I tried to avoid it.
Okay,
here we go.
So I began,
it began,
here's the argument.
Uh,
she told me,
um,
I played high school,
thought Arthur,
I know sports.
This made me snap because she was bringing up high school credits to me,
which people really don't do around me.
Uh,
people don't do that around me,
I guess for good reason.
In high school,
I was ranked number one in the state for three different sports ranked
nationally and football.
I was inducted into the high school football hall of fame at the age of 21
played division one ball on a full scholarship and was projected to go seventh
in the draft until I blew my knee out.
I gotta ask you a question,
dude.
Blew me knee out.
Are you from like England?
We are playing footy.
We talking soccer over there.
At this point I thought you were like maybe that,
that guy that fucking running back there that went to buffalo from Ohio state.
Um,
no,
but he did go,
he did go number one in the first round.
Anyone.
He pretended to talk on a cell phone to a team,
but he was really talking to his agent.
The fuck was that guy's name.
Anyways.
Um,
I don't,
um,
Willis mcgahee.
All right,
continue bill.
Fine.
Um,
I don't bring this stuff up ever.
So she,
uh,
she might not have known,
but she baited me and I felt like putting her in her place.
I was starting to get arrogant but still making my point.
So you're basically telling her that you were ranked number one in three
different sports and you would have been seventh in the draft,
but you blow out your knee.
Dude,
I wish I was there to see that.
That's a great one.
I bet that shutter down.
Uh,
but she baited me and I felt like putting her in a place I was starting to get
arrogant.
No,
not you,
dude.
You're down to earth.
Um,
but still making my point of why sports are such a money grabber.
I said,
over 60,000 people come out every Saturday to uh,
every,
every over 60,000 people came out every Saturday to watch what me and my friends
do athletically and we weren't even getting paid.
She interrupted with I don't care.
Um,
then she started talking about women's soccer against.
So I interrupted her by saying I have never played soccer in my life,
but I can guarantee you that I am better at it than you are.
Dude,
will you blue you like leaning over a table of coronas pointing in her face at
this,
at this point,
and are you much bigger than her than her,
her fucking boyfriend that he didn't try to step in?
Oh God,
I you fucking made this would've been a great youtube video.
Um,
anyways.
Now what I meant by that was I was probably twice as fast,
five times stronger and have enough natural coordination to pick up soccer and
be as good,
if not better at it than you,
because I'm a pretty high level athlete.
What she heard was all men are better at sports than ever than every woman.
She got emotional,
but her anger held back the tears while I was just trying to figure out,
while I was just trying to figure out how the conversation got to this point.
Well if you want to figure out how it got to that point,
let's start with your opening line of like,
oh,
you're one of those women.
I know enough not to get into an argument the with the fucking woman like you,
you know,
come on dude,
you baited her into it.
You obeyed it or into it.
You wanted to have the argument because you love yelling at women.
And I relate.
I'm not judging you.
Um,
you know,
it's not like you're on people magazine holding up the woman that you were
yelling at,
cause you just adopted her like Sandra Bullock.
Look what I did.
Um,
Ortho.
Yay.
Um,
she got emotional,
but I ain't going to help back on tears.
Well,
up,
up and up and up.
Finally my friends stepped in and I settled down.
Uh,
she just,
she got silent for a bit,
but she sparked back up when I brought up ed hardy shirts,
the ones that are so colorful and bedazzled and Warren,
a couple of sizes too small by dudes.
Uh,
she said I don't got it.
I don't get why guys wear stuff like that.
Girls don't like girls don't like it.
I came back as I came back and said as before,
I agree that the shirts are dumb,
but girls actually do love that shit dude.
You just love fucking pissing off women best what you do.
You're just arguing with this woman on every fucking point.
That's what you're doing.
Um,
and I think it's fucking hilarious cause I've done this.
I am this guy.
Did I write this?
Then I get drunk and send myself a fucking email.
Anyways,
she replied with,
are you going to tell me that you know more about girls than I do too?
Then I do also basically he said to which I said yes and he finally admits,
I think I was trying to fight at this point.
We were on bottles seven of wine.
Uh,
I said,
you obviously know more about what it's like to be a woman.
I'm sorry,
my screen just went blank.
You obviously know what more of what it's like to be a woman than me.
Yeah.
But figuring out what girls want in a man is our job as guys,
since I was 14,
I've been studying this shit.
I spent more time learning about girls in college than I did about my,
about my degree.
Uh,
she made some more dumb points,
mostly just angry at me saying,
well,
I don't like the shirts and I'm,
and I'm a girl.
So there you go.
Anyways,
uh,
you know how when you're drunk you get better at arguing,
but mercy,
worse at,
uh,
coming up with solid points.
I couldn't think of how to explain this to her,
but a classic bill,
Bill Burr Line came into my head.
I told her,
you don't get it.
Men literally have to develop a skill to get women to like them.
Uh,
and then he writes,
which is a great line by the way,
but I may have taken it too far and he goes on to say it's not love at first
sight and all that soulmate shit.
Men have to purposely take steps to get you separate.
Like to separate yourself from the crowd.
The feelings part,
the feelings part might be out of our hands.
But to set up those things is an easy,
and unless you're wearing some sparkly shirt,
most of my closest friends wear those shirts and trust me it works.
I'm not saying you're stupid.
Uh,
I may,
I may have said that part a little sarcastically core.
Shuer um,
but let's pretend that me and my friends have only ess,
but let's pretend that me and my friends have only slept with 50 girls each.
That means I've partly personally witnessed why over 300 girls have slept with
guys plus add up all the times.
We all stuck.
We all struck out.
And why?
I think I'm pretty experienced in knowing what girls like.
Um,
how many girls have,
have you convinced to fuck you?
Um,
this is when she cried.
What I didn't know was she used to be a lesbian.
She quit being a lesbian to be with my friend and she is sensitive about it.
Yeah.
I would think she would be sensitive about it.
Considering you can't quit being a lesbian,
you either are one or you aren't one.
Yeah.
You know,
I kind of blew a couple of guys but I quit.
Yeah.
I didn't like it made me paranoid.
Went back to vet Janie's.
Um,
anyways,
he said I became the I at that point I became the asshole.
I left a bar thinking two things.
One,
why did it have to shit?
I said come out with a Boston fucking accent.
And after realizing this,
uh,
after realizing the reason why I thought,
fuck,
I got to stop listening to the Goddamn podcast.
Can you believe this fucking guy?
I mean,
there must've been 22 off ramps he could have taken as that thing developed into
a major fight and he chose to stay on the highway and then in the end he comes
around and he tries to fucking blame me.
Dude.
The reason why you listened to this podcast is because you're just like me now
because I've created yeah,
me inside of you.
All right the fuck dude.
Come on,
admit it.
You like doing it.
I like doing it.
I love the women go in there and they,
and they,
and they make some stupid fucking statement.
I love at that point,
I love trashing them because so many guys just stand there and they just stay.
They just sit there and agree and they let them say stupid fucking things with
no points behind it because they're,
they're still in that adolescent.
Keep it happy.
It'll fuck me.
And it gets annoying and you just sit there and you watch one guy after another
getting played for free fucking drinks,
you know Carrie and shit for him,
helping him to move and it makes you fucking annoyed after awhile makes you
annoyed.
But uh,
then then what you do is you get involved in shit like that and you absolutely
bury him.
Let me ask you this dude,
how many times,
how many times were you fucking standing up pointing at her?
Huh?
Be Honest.
You know,
you even alluded to it yourself,
where you just sitting there going like,
maybe I said that a little sarcastically.
Of course you did.
You know
whatever dude.
You know,
you fucking,
yeah,
you got issues with women sort of way.
Welcome.
Fucking join the Goddamn club.
Don't play make,
don't fucking blame me.
Go find out where the meeting is and then tell me where I can go with like a
couple of guys with,
with drinking problems.
So if you find out,
uh,
yeah,
I don't even think what you did was that bad.
I don't think it justifies fucking crying either.
I think that whole thing is annoying.
You know what?
I'm going to stop this podcast here because it's already been over a fucking
hour and I know by the end of this I'm gonna end up agreeing with this fucking
guy,
which I don't want to do because this guy is me.
I'd say about 18 months ago,
I've actually made some strides.
Have an eye Cleo,
right?
I got a female dog,
didn't I?
I got a bitch laying at my feet.
All right.
Whatever.
There you go.
Another jet lag podcast.
Everybody congratulations to Philadelphia Flyers on fucking Poland for you guys.
It could be great to see you guys win a championship or even the fucking,
uh,
eastern conference finals.
God knows you'd be,
you'd be more better behaved than those assholes up in Montreal who burned down
their fucking city every time they win.
And then they look down on us because we're fat fucks.
At least we don't like shit on fire.
You fucking pyromaniac.
Granted we don't because some of so many of us are so flammable because of all
that fucking Lard we have inside of us went out.
What's up,
man?
I'm with a fat joke.
I like that people get hurt this week.
All right.
That's the podcast.
God bless all you and I will,
uh,
I'll talk to you next week.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
mm.
[inaudible].